[Music]
well hurricane durian makes its way
toward the Florida coast not everyone is
fleeing the fierce storm we fly fast we
fly high so we can cover a lot of area
commander Rebecca Waddington lieutenant
Lindsay Norman and captain Kristy
twining flew into the eye of the storm
this week their hurricane hunter
aircraft collects data for NOAA which
helps the forecasters predict where the
storm is heading next but their flight
Thursday was historic it was the first
time in NOAA's history that a hurricane
hunters flight crew was composed of all
women there's more women getting
interested in flying and it's also fun
to have that camaraderie because it's
you know to be honest it's been it's
been a male-dominated field this photo
was snapped on board the aircraft ahead
of their mission celebrating its
significance twining hopes they will
inspire a new generation of female
pilots to let them know that this is a
you know certainly a possibility for
them and they don't have to feel
intimidated or in any way think that
they cannot do it people think you're a
little bit nuts but then when you tell
them oh well this is why we're going out
and doing this collecting all this
really important data then people are
usually really grateful for what you
doing I love that people think we're a
little bit nuts but grateful thank you
you're fun to watch yeah